eccoci eccoci benvenuti era la puntata
del blog mas in questo evento siamo a
milano non si direbbe perché c'è il sole
ogni volta che siamo sentiti a milano
nella vigna ultimamente calcolate da
novembre
l'acqua saliamo fino alle ginocchia in
realtà ci siamo allenati con la
pellegrini per vincere non in piedi di
tokyo dei 100 metri stile grande albergo
per prepararci al volo visto che stiamo
andando a fare un'attività finissima con
la apple premi workshop di fotografia al
telefono nel frattempo mi rise e mi dice
che sono troppo lento per i suoi gusti
apri colpisce a sapere vaticano aveva
preso una macchina gettare 130 lei
questo qui è un posto già libero veniva
la fortuna aiuta gli audaci va beh
finisco questo discorso attentamente di
macchina si incamera in un'altra
macchina siamo arrivati in questa
graziosa stanza c'è anche un bel van
gogh di quelli originali quello che
faremo oggi è andare alle posto a quello
in via del liberty a fare un'attività
con la apple
io sono molto emozionato non è un
segreto che sia un grandissimo fan
quindi speriamo che non voglio fare
tardi non fatemi fare queste figure rino
come cappato da una nota che si
sciolgono
è in corso in realtà per non dà tutto a
volo d'angelo satto hai mai provato a
partners primo e non riesco più tardi
sono recato nievole passatore
minimissimo l'italia
ma stiamo scherzando
c'è manco a disneyland ora mi butto
nella fontana ma perché devo farlo hanno
scoperto era la mela ma mai non ho ma
resta
varedo si ferma rinvio del congresso
esperienza troppo bagnato dove vi devo
dire
stiamo facendo la carreggiata
grazia che pensa che ci stavo per
preparare per andare a fare un'ora corso
da tempo
non fatevi regalare a quell anno scorso
c 10 o arrivo quest'anno vediamo 16 10 e
giammarco lui m'ha regalato herbie non
ci credo pensava capito di essere un
signore vediamo adesso come la mettiamo
visto che una tale bisogna fare i
signori vediamo il pollino
volante
questo qui è il modello che abbiamo
scelto secondo me gli vogliamo che il
suo scuro grigio scuro ce l'ha già e
rido io so in rosa parliamo chiaro
grigio chiaro se lo vuole no no grigio
scuro tutta la vita
grazie a river entrare
se già male
guardate qua sotto quello di como
continua a farlo all'infinito così
piacevano è bellissimo però
adesso devo intrattenere giammarco che i
ragazzi che stanno facendo il computer
quindi
eccoli
bello lo store madonna anche io voglio
andare a portare lamela
e tu mi
per lamela no non ho voglia di toccare
la vera acqua da adesso si vede
mi ricorda quasi tutto incerti come il
numero
vabbè louvre il louvre però molto
stiloso questo portò allo zaino
che fate stava intrattenendo il pubblico
con occhiali macchina o un qualcosa per
intrattenerlo
auguri
sì
una scatola
a loro città natale anche per lui mi ha
mai un computer si trova bene ci credo
ragazzi
ma cosa ho fatto per meritare questa
cosa tanto per non accorgersene tutti a
dare tutto il mio se è il corso di una
calda il corso di fotografia
facciamo anche il corso di tutto per via
ma dobbiamo arti con l'inganno capito
non ci credo bene questo è il giorno più
bello della mia vita ma considera che vi
parlavamo di piccole simili scusate
questa camera per il mango del telefono
finalmente sono di carta e buste e
questo e carta è una fibra di carta well
done
adesso stava in paranoia del tutto il
pomeriggio europea che si amano come si
dice sci di scorsa che tu arrivo che
state sbattendo in maniera assurda
dai quindi l'anno scorso e rigo serviva
perché sono stato resa non potevo di
sfruttarlo
restando che sa sfruttare gianmarco
dovrei ripagarlo con tintin settore
della tua fredda la mia mancanza di
empatia non fa vedere quanto realtà di
te lo so in questo momento questo è come
se un bambino stesse piangendo
felicissimo esterno forte ma in realtà
sono elemento veramente
o di gioia puro per me si dice in
maniera molto semplice ci riesci a dare
alla apple in mutante a milano dai basta
e ripagarsi ma poi cioè se o per le
persone pensano che siamo troppo troppo
generosi a sappiamo anche essere
creativi egoisti molto raramente ci
piace un regalo c'è pure il cosa di
carta
voi non avete mai vorrei avere o esatto
una catena da ancora armi alla mano per
iniziare l'incontro
adesso veramente faccio una cosa che
divertimento che ho aiutato quella
principi e cina
waters resiste resiste ma non è vero
avellino ogni fatto fammi qualche
ripresa che con questa luce sempre bordo
una sorta di unione tra vari esposizioni
di luce della foto che prende che fare
allora
esatto l'hanno 10 poi tecnico andando a
fare le foto fuori allora di mettere in
pratica la mia abilità fotografica
stanco
ho perso sette anni di vita non è 4
puntavo ceres e monteleone ce l'avevo
devo dire che la via per fare le cose
che avevo un iphone ma tutto cristo ad
un iphone 11 15
enrico per favore visto buttando in
mezzo io sono reparti carte nella sfida
del passato e giacomo da tempo di elmo
siamo nelle tue mani che ho visto cosa
stanno facendo gli altri sta facendo da
tappo e delfino kacar e non possiamo
avere la vedo molto difficile che
vinciamo
gli scavi del tondino metti lei
sei tu che mi metti l'ansia da
prestazione
alla faccia della versana tipo gufo al
pubblico da casa di votare per me sento
che sta per partire il kilt mantini più
fermo il più possibile teneva come
sostiene che se vai grazie ma si può
cambiare il modello ma e mia mamma che
mi ha fatto così bene
a 700 la cacca perché ho imparato una
cosa che non sapevo non si sa che se tu
fai una foto live tipo questa file
effetto romito persone e mezzo
la gente che si muove ho pensato di
farlo anch'io con gianmarco facendogli
girare il braccio in modo di torre di
lui e questo ventaglio bellissimo questo
è quello che è successo the ring samara
abbiamo forse un po migliore della
tecnica o altro
è molto interessante sono arrivato a
casa qui da lui sto aspettando che mi
arrivi il globo però prima di dormire
volevo dirvi una cosa che figata
sono estremamente contento in primis e
sono molto contento ricavano foto gianni
so che gli ha fatto piacere sono
soltanto perché a parte gli torna su
glutine perché così potrà anche
sfruttarlo meglio e inoltre me lo dire
questa cosa però scoperti realtà solo
oggi a tutti continua gli amanti della
apple
se volete imparare delle cose nuove ma
dalle basi a rabbia più fighette
scaricate l'app apple store
questa qua non so se vedete praticamente
al centro c'è un pulsante in basso che
calendario che sto facendo una ripresa
orribile saper vedere la scena aspettate
mi è arrivato un po che comunque diciamo
però sapevo e spacca se volete imparare
a usare meglio però se dispositivi ma
soprattutto imparare cose nuove anche la
professionisti promessa serve sempre
accesso fotografo molto molto bravo
cielo 6 rubato dopo tre che sono pure
gratuiti come forse bisogna
semplicemente iscriversi di andare a
ecco potrei andare sull'app che avevo
detto prima che è qua sotto vedete
calendario vedere tutti quanti gli
incontri dove specie di workshop e
segnarne uno di questi è sono per tutti
cioè puoi partire dal sono una schiappa
col telefono ha voglia approfondire
architettura e design
voglio approfondire altri ambiti di
poker la musica video making la
fotografia il disegno è una cosa molto
molto bella perché è un modo sempre per
promuovere la creatività detto ciò
quindi bella magno senza 2 gr farla
nemmeno notte a domani con altro blog ma
spero
fammi un saluto a tutte le persone la
manina